should we believe anything that this
Administration tells us about anything
ever again Secretary of Defense Lloyd
Austin uh he was MIA for about a week uh
and well we've got some info here from
the daily wire the story is just
absolutely insane Secretary of Defense
Lloyd Austin remained hospitalized on
Sunday night after being rushed to the
hospital at the start of the New Year
After experiencing severe pain as he
recovered late last month from an
elective procedure the Pentagon said in
a statement that Austin remained at the
Walter Reed National military Medical
Center but was recovering well and in
good spirits The Wall Street Journal
reported that Austin had an undisclosed
elective procedure on December 22nd
during scheduled leave and returned home
the following day on January 1st Austin
experienced severe pain and was rushed
to Walter Reid where he was admitted
into its Intensive Care Unit the report
said the report said that the White
House was not notified of the situation
because Austin chief Austin's chief of
Staff uh Kelly maiman was simultaneously
out at the same time with the flu and
because chairman of the G Joint Chiefs
of Staff uh General CQ Brown was not
wasn't bound to tell the White House as
an as a subordinate advisory all right
so do you get what just happened here so
the guy has surgery we'll have more on
that in just a second he dips out they
don't tell the White House they don't
tell the white house because his number
two is on vacation the one after that
they're claiming there's some chain of
command thing just seems a little ODOT
you know you'd think the White House
might know if the head of the military
at the moment right the defense
secretary do you think that if he was
out for an afternoon that somebody might
need to know about that anyway Peter duy
over at Fox one of the few people that I
can call a journalist without you using
air quotes here he is asking White House
spokesman John Kirby how this possibly
happened and could they be lying about
someone else's Health if they've been
lying about Lloyd Austin's health and
we'll get more to l atin's Health in
just a sec why should we believe
anything that this Administration tells
us about anything ever again I think we
all recognize and I think the Pentagon
has
been very very honest with themselves
about uh the um the challenge to to to
credibility by what by what has
transpired here and by what and by
uh uh how
how how hard it was for them to be fully
transparent with the American people I
think we all recognize that the
administration is going to go to Such
Great Lengths to keep secrets about the
defense secretary's Health how can
anybody be certain that the
administration would not go to the same
lengths to keep secret problems with
President Biden's help in the future if
if you could logically argue and you
can't but if you could logically argue
that the he's 81 years old wait a second
just give me a second here BB I'll get
there if if the administration made some
sort of Machiavellian effort uh across
the board to just to to keep this from
getting public then I think your
question has Merit and and certainly is
a fair one I don't think it's a fair one
because that's not what happened here
Peter what happened here is the
Secretary of Defense uh for whatever
reason I can't answer the question why
that information wasn't shared it wasn't
shared widely in the department and it
certainly wasn't shared with
the not good it's certainly not good
which is why again we want to learn from
this we want to we want to make sure
that it doesn't happen again all right
there's just so much nonsense there I
mean the main question that we all had
in this room was what is going on with
that guy's shoulder pads I mean he's
making be Arthur proud right like
there's some Michael Scott level
shoulder pads there um also he's like I
can't how could I answer why the guy
wouldn't tell us what he was doing who
who do you think I am I'm the I'm the
White House Press Secretary I'm not
somebody that's supposed to know
something it's just absolutely absurd of
course the the broader point that we all
every sane person in America right now
has let's just say some slight uh
curiosity as it relates to Joe Biden's
Health right the stammering the
confusion the falling asleep the
wandering out into the forest like
there's a bunch of stuff that I think
legitimately we could ask about what
Kirby tries to do there is make it seem
like the only way you could really ask
about that is if it was some Mass
Machiavellian plan across the board
everybody knew it might be a pretty
small conspiracy it might only be a
conspiracy Dr Jill Biden and don't you
forget she's a doctor and Joe Biden's
physician whoever is giving him the
drugs and they obviously are and a
couple other people I think it's
possible that John Kirby doesn't even
know what's going on but that doesn't
mean that nothing is going
on